this episode of the pain game podcast is
sponsored by surf shock surfshock is a
virtual private network that you can use
as an app or browser extension it lets
you place yourself anywhere in the world
and allows you to access the internet as
if you were in another country so let's
say you wanted to re-watch fury wilder
but from the american point of view you
could use save shark to put yourself in
america watch their coverage you could
hear their commentary and witness tyson
fury winning it all in their backyard oh
i bet they were gutted so if you want to
check it out go and click the link in
the description below and use the code
jordy to get 83
off with three months extra for free
also serve shop offer a 30-day
money-back guarantee so there's no risk
to try it out you think i'm done nah got
another one for you they also let you
use one account on all your devices so
they've just got you covered so big
thanks to surfshark for sponsoring this
episode but for now enjoy the
[Music]
podcast at one time i was homeless
instead of going home every night there
was no home to go to
life at home was very difficult i grew
up being abused
i lost my belt i lost respect i
embarrassed my family my vision was
pretty much non-existent i was able to
just about scrape by the medicals
i come out i have supreme confidence i'm
scared to death
i'm afraid of everything
i didn't care about living i just wanted
to die i got up and i felt the weight of
the world was lifted off my shoulders i
knew i was going to make a comeback
[Music]
this was designed for me to do what
makes us who we are
i'm so far ahead again
my dream
my vision for myself is to be the
greatest martial artist to ever live i
have always been a fighter there is
nothing i do better in this life than
fighting
there ain't never been a man that could
get to me i was born to do this
[Music]
all right my name's brian mate i don't
know if you remember meeting us before i
do i'll come with tyson on your shoulder
yes i wasn't actually aware of what a
crack and talk are you at the time
otherwise it would have been uh it would
have been you and him but uh here we are
i got you finally uh hey thanks for
having me on the show absolutely uh it's
an honor me i i think you're uh
one of the most entertaining speakers in
the sport of boxing and uh thank you i'm
a huge uh boxing fan um
god knows what must be going through
your head after a whirlwind uh what what
is it like to just finally look at the
trilogy complete with deontay wilder and
know
your son came out on top mate
it's a relief
because he was the hardest to ever wake
the last 60 or 70 years probably of this
century to be honest with you because
nobody's out of the wild i can see from
the right and he took his old body
covered like a jelly on a plate
you know so it was always danger and he
was like he was like a wounded tiger was
because he could he could arm you still
at any time you know i've got to get out
of the way
yeah i was uh i mean i'm a huge fan of
tyson and i was i think the most worried
i've ever been
wha how worried were you when you went
down uh in that fourth round twice um i
was worried because it was early on in
the fight you know and i thought you
know what to get dropped in the fourth
round but he made a rookie error and
walked straight on to a powerful right
hand which had never seen tyson do
before to be fair he's generally clever
than that but what happened was he tried
to pick a wounded tiger up by the tail
didn't he and he got caught you know a
rookie error but he paid the price for
it you know but he was hit badly
at some stage you know i think he was
more than when he got went from the
first for a while to fight to be honest
sorry that was the same shot that i
think uh luis ortiz got flattened with
absolutely i think that aired more than
when he got when he was out on his backs
he got up and he he looked stronger when
he got up the first time because he was
a bit he was a bit drugging when he got
this time to be fair it was a hell of a
shock though
yeah
when someone goes down a second time
that early
you just don't see them go on and win
the fight
uh and i guess that's testament to what
a amazing
gutsy performance it was from tyson you
talked about the uh the fact that he got
hit with that kind of shot um a few
people have said it wasn't the
the best version of tyson technically
speaking
um why do you think that was he never
had time to prepare properties nothing
but problems leading up to the fight
he got covered in july when it's meant
to take place there got back in his
daughter
was uh gravely ill and he spent two
weeks on the floor of a hospital you
know he didn't get out the hospital
until the fourth or fifth of september
and he did that four weeks later you
know because he went running with me
whilst he was in liverpool and to be
honest with you he was all out after the
three mile run i finished fitter than
him
56 year old and 20 stone his lungs on
fire i could hear him breathing like a
wooden horse you know and at the end of
the day i thought you know what
how are we gonna get this but he said
look i've got to do it
because of my fans
they've waited so long he said i don't
want to lose face i'm going to fight
this man if i've got one leg he said but
i've got one leg on one arm i'm fighting
wilder that's what he did you know and i
was worried about it from start to
finish but we put a brave face on
did no negativity at all it was all
positive all positive stuff and we just
wanted to make him as positive about it
as you possibly could he knew he was
going to do it anyway
yeah
i've never seen tyson look that tired
during
the middle of a fight i was that was
where
the fears were really gripping like me
and all my mates were watching and we
were all panicking at this point
um
but he did pull through and he always
does seem to pull through and and that's
the the sort of special thing i guess
about him
where does this come from do you think
where's that inner belief coming from
you're born with that you know i've told
him all his life
that nobody can beat you so you've got
ability to burn you've got to have to
burn you've got to drive to bed nobody
can equal you in any department and i
instilled that in from being seven or
eight year old you know because i knew
he had a lot and i said the only one man
can ever beat you so that's yourself you
know and this tremendous but it's a dna
thing
it's got to be because and i've never
seen that kind of will and desire
especially when you're in football like
that because it's all over in the fourth
round if you said to me okay
it's gonna get stopped next i wouldn't
have been so surprised but he went on
again he had that look in his eye got up
but here we are again right dog fight
trench is not exactly what he went in
i've never seen a heavyweight fighter
take punishment and get dropped and
actually
is is generally more scary after you
drop him that's
it's an unusual thing isn't it
he just thought like he just said it
influx of power anxiety like somebody
put a jump back on him yeah he's like
somebody objecting with venom and
on hell intentions you know because
after the sixth round fifth and sixth
and seventh he was getting stronger and
stronger but
inactivity had a lot to play played a
big part in that because he'd been out
for 20 months a lot of problems and i
don't think he settled before 67 rounds
tyson
i think he took him seven rounds to
settle into it
his timing didn't seem to be the the the
normal timing that we see from fury it
took him a while he was 60 percent of
what he should have been
how can you prepare in three or four
weeks max and you know he hardly done
any road work you could see by it by by
his body that he was he was uh he could
have done better yeah you know he was
relying on brains skill and heart will
and determination to bring him home and
it didn't end in a thrilling affair but
could have been better
oh yes
it makes you think what
you know no wonder deontay wilder
accused him of cheating because he must
be so
mentally broken by the fact that this
guy
you know tyson when he came in the first
fight probably had his weakest
physically
and then in in the third fight maybe at
his least fit we've seen him and and you
still couldn't get him out of there you
know like what well
i just think that was the best deontay
wilder we've seen i do
and sixty percent at ice and that still
wasn't enough you know and at the end of
the day you'll never keep this guy down
he's a he's a gigantic man with a heart
as big as himself and i'm his father
don't know where it comes from you know
because i've never seen it in a fighter
before that wouldn't desire when
you shouldn't be winning
he's doing things you can't do he's
doing the impossible he had three weeks
training for that on the training
basically with just firing of gym work a
bit of bad work sparring
on a bit of strength and conditioning
where it's all he had he never had time
to know adults you know like i say we
could have done with it being put back a
bit but he said no but i can't put it
back no more because i didn't want to
fight him i said look this is this is
ridiculous so how can you fight this
fellow he's been training for 18 months
for you as he's had plenty of time to
get over his whooping i said now he's
put a year's training on and off and
they've got it right which big up to
malik scotty done a good job and i'll
take it back about the kid what i said
about him
i said he couldn't
improve him but he did and i'm a man who
admits when he's wrong
yeah when it came out london those there
was stiff body shots
for all deontay was clearly uh he looked
tense and he looked very nervous
they were having an impact and i was i
was worried because obviously the
movement of fury is what we expect and
you you know we expected that to slow
him down a bit
um to credit them alex scott but in
terms of deontay you know after three
fights you thought that had been a
handshake there what do you make of that
the lack of respect at the end
well he just made a great performance
for himself didn't he and he showed like
his childish characteristics again i
don't like wild as a man at all he'd
never be on my christmas card list i'd
never say anything good about him only
he's fighting ability because he's got
nothing else good about it he can punch
and he's got art he's got to worry as
well but that's all he's got was a man
or anything else zero but did he put a
good performance up that night course he
did it takes two to tango and it made a
great evening in the boxing one of the
greatest heavyweight title fights you'll
see in some time and it takes two to
tango he played his part but a horrible
horrible horrible man
because anybody shake hands after what
they've been through they've batted each
other to a pool you'd think the last
thing that i've okay we'll put our
differences to one side i'm gonna shake
your hand mate you beat me three times
there's man there's me out we'll have a
drink sometime you know it was worthy of
that and more but what do they get and
nothing i don't respect you as a sport
i've got no respect for it at all and i
told tyson i said listen tyson don't
show him no respect at the end of it
don't shake his hand don't don't think
but tyson's a lovely guy
he's been brought up to show respect and
put his hand out shake hands we're
fighting people
fights i've had in the lifetime the
voice shook hands afterwards so he's
been the worst enemy we shook hands
afterwards it's a fight we put our
differences to one side we shake hands
have a pint of beer if you want to be in
the enemy on monday you can't be that's
how we work it feels like uh
deontay just can't accept it you know he
knocked out whatever it was 40 people
solid
and then this one guy who we sort of
picked on thinking eyes out of shape
it'll be a nice easy win on my resume
and then i'll move on to anthony joshua
and you know the gypsy king comes and
shocks the world three times over and he
just can't accept that someone else is
better than him and you're right it is
childish and it's a shame like you say
it was one of the greatest fights i've
ever seen and even mike tyson someone
who obviously you were inspired by and
gave your son his name said you know
that was a they went down as the great
and specifically tyson fury is an
all-time great what is it like to hear
mike tyson call your son an all-time
great boxer
absolutely the feeling can't be
described with any kind of words
i've always been a big big big fan of
their mike tyson i called me boy after
him you know he's probably up there with
the best of them as well mike tyson all
those guys if they just mention my son
as being up there with them not better
being with them that's good enough for
me i'm ecstatic i'm on cloud nine i've
never felt as good in my life i feel
positive about everything i was a little
bit worried about my son's health
because i don't like him taking too many
shots from the brain area like he did
and
you know he took a lot of stick in that
fight he was walled up he knew he'd been
a fight you saw the next day and i hoped
him while i said on the thing to him but
he phoned me i said this is the world of
fisticuffs tyson he said i know that
this is what i signed on for and when i
climb in that ring that'll be the best
that possibly can be i will never be
denied he said that don't ever doubt me
as a son i've never doubted you you
fought like a trooper to live to get
into the world and you're fighting now
you know you change the world and let me
tell you something
gypsy people
don't put crowns on outhouses
he's not a king for nothing
he's a king of every gypsy in the world
and they are a lot of people and they
respect people and they're not ordinary
people to get to be called the king of
the gypsies
can can you um can you elaborate a
little i mean actually as it happens my
my dad recently um educated me on uh
my bloodline and how we have our travel
our bloodline and um what what it means
to
the people to to give him such a title
and and sort of how he's revered by them
let me tell you about gypsy people you
know they're all
for the self you know they're all they
all look after drone ship the one man
armies will listen they all pay homage
to a king like him
because everyone with a drain an ounce
of travel and blood them know that
they they recognize greatness when they
see it in him and they just admire it
look up to him and
you just open the floodgates for every
traveler child gypsy wanted to be a
boxer so now they're going to put more
time into it and i'm sure you'll see
more champions come now through tyson
through the traveling community like
before they got married at 15 16
whatever they're going to do and set off
and it was making their own living they
had no time to box for free they
attained pulling into your child fathers
or so he's having kids runner 17 18 but
now that's different that's different
now through tyson billy jost
yeah i think um obviously tyson
he's become a champion of of mental
health as well and a lot of things
but um
i feel like you know the the travelers
were
aside from some of the tv shows that
were made about them which let's be
honest we're
often popping fun poking fun a little
bit a bit like you know some of the
shows made about jodie's for christ's
sake
um
he's i feel like he's sort of um
redefined uh the way people see
uh the traveler community so you know um
i'm sure a lot of them are grateful for
that uh deontay wilder on the other hand
uh moving forward
where do you think he goes from here
because it was a great performance but
you know he lost and sometimes that
people are never the same after a
beating like where he received twice in
a row now
that's a good point because how much as
it took out of dante while two good
beats in a row you know i don't know
what he's got left he's 36 years old i
think this time october time he's 36 and
uh how much desires he got left all
right much as i took out one can it be
replaced because you know something i
honestly don't think while it'll ever be
the same again and i think once he
settles down
and looks in the coal like today might
think you know what i've done all
accounting i'm 36 i've made millions of
dollars i'm going to call it a draw yeah
you know and don't forget about it and
he's close up but you never know boxers
it's like a drug to us a bigger drug
than cocaine
to a box so you're not saying because he
can't give it up it's like me i train
still today i run every day hit the bags
you know even though i'm not the
chilling bit but i still do it don't say
it because i can't help it i love doing
it yeah you know well that's the same
box as they can't leave it alone
apparently has already said that he's
talking about making a comeback um
where would you rank him in in terms of
other
fighters right now because obviously
we've got usic and aj we've got the uh
dillian white and a few other
heavyweights out there otto wallin
where do you put him roughly a country
mile second best of all the others
you know because he knocks all the moves
out goal
he knocks too sick out he knocks aj out
and they haven't got the will and desire
thais has to overcome him and if he's if
he if he'd if if deontay wilde
put a box any other heavyweights on the
planet saturday night he got victory
yeah he'd got the victory without even a
shadow of that who said joshua's them
all
you know but tyson he'd come up again a
special human being
but one that's got an incredible engine
he can do 12 rounds not fit you know and
this man will not will not go away he's
on you all night long because he wants
to win he wants to win he's got that
undying belief in himself and he says
right to me for my boy dad
i am willing to die in that room
i will die try it he said because i'd
rather be dead than be beat in that room
and that's that's his motto
as his dad does that
it does because i know i know and
everybody else knows he'll go away with
it it's been proven like when he got up
in the fourth round he was all over the
place
he never had much left in him but he dug
and drove and found something else and
he picked down his dumpster thought
right i said i was gonna die i'll tell
you what i'm gonna die try it
and he just he just it's unbelievable
it's beggar's belief what i was seeing
from my own son
he's actually actually practiced what
he's been preaching to me all his life
and i'm so proud of him
no you should be you should be me i mean
we were all gone
we were gobsmacked in the studio like if
any i mean you know
you're
he's your son but i i felt like
emotional at the end of that fight it's
it's one of those roller coasters that
we all went on and you you're staggered
and and to be fair while that did help
me he he he fought at the bit around and
when you look at the commitment both men
showed to go out on their shield to give
everything they had especially and i
think it was even more amazing
only weeks uh one or two weeks after
anthony joshua's last fight where he
showed so little commitment and so
little willing to go out on his shield
and was very reserved i think it it
almost made the fight even more it
showed even more
uh how powerful it was
well you've only got to look at joshua's
body language after the fight his
behavior on the stool hmm
it's behavior warriors don't behave like
like if you look at look at deontay
wilder dante well have dipped his head
much to say i've given me all i can't do
anymore
and he was just all out but he wasn't
making any motions like he wasn't tall
he wasn't discomforted yeah he wasn't
like like trying to do anything but soak
it all in
john t wilder fought his heart up he had
nothing left at all you know and i think
he was teaching on being conscious
when you're certainly still that's how
hard he fought you know aj
he didn't do anything wrong you can only
do what you can do in boxing he just
hasn't got the desire of a will not a
quarter of it of these other two men
while they're all myself but listen he's
been a good champion but does he ever
beat these other two men definitely not
he's not a one function or cat artist
like wilder either the the word you use
there behaving i think that's a great
word and i've heard uh i've heard teddy
atlas use this word before as well where
he talks about behaving like a fighter
and yeah with aj obviously he's got so
much natural ability as an athlete but
but when you're seeing him get knocked
down by ruiz and the referee looks at
him and asks do you want to continue
and his body language is all wrong and
then again when music is getting the
better of him the body language and
that's it for me as well as that's why i
don't think he beats either of those two
either i think i think he should beat
wilder i think he's got a better rounded
game than wilder but i just think that
wilder like you say he wants it so bad
and that that right hand is a killer
the minute he stings aj with a right
hand like that while it's good night for
aj yeah because he hasn't got the
resilience to cope with anything like
that and believe me you sec is not the
punctual wild risk
yeah to be honest with you you know
he's not a knockout he's a respectable
poacher you sick he's an airport
you'll just switch your lights off
completely and aj you can't deal with it
nobody else can imagine wilder they're
out there
what were you thinking as you're
watching the aj you sick fight because
it felt like the fight just sort of
passed aj by while yousek just wrapped
up the rounds
well i'll tell you what i got he was
just trying to stay in the game
he felt u6 power early on with the left
hand straight down the pipe in about the
first of the second round for hang on he
made his mind up then yeah i can't take
this power i've got to watch i don't get
knocked out me he just settled
for second best as long as he finished
on his feet he did enough to keep him in
the fight instead of trying to win
you've got to try and win he was in
tottenham three mile from his house he
was defending his country he should have
defended like tyson defends it he didn't
do that he just want to get his money
and run but there's a difference tyson's
a warrior
he's a fighting man he's a businessman
of the poster boy it's a big difference
you know what i'm saying but for what he
is he's done very very well anybody who
can pick a world championship belt up
you know i mean had it given to him by
this uh other fella when he took it off
charles martin and they had to rob it
off my son in the beginning to give him
it or he's never been champion
only for my son beating klitschko while
joshua would never ever rather belt he's
absolutely he would have had to go win
it proper and he weren't capable beating
any of those guys
he's proved it i mean
when you talk about settling for second
best
when when you when you're defending your
title you i think you have to mentally
fight as if like you're competing for
the title and the belts are for grabs
and he didn't he didn't have that eye of
the tiger he didn't go out there and go
you know it is i've lost nine rounds i'm
just gonna go out and try and win and if
i lose and get knocked out i'll lose he
didn't commit like that and even at the
end when you sick was all over him
you've seen him sort of walk off and go
as if i survived and i thought myself
that's that's not the mentality i'm
expecting from someone trying to win a
world title
definitely not when you when you're
fighting for yourself
your own self and your country and your
fans you've got to be a die hard man you
know
you know
nobody wants to die in the room but
that's the profession you've adopted
this is this is what you're getting paid
to do you've got to make the best
possible job of it and i would rather
get knocked out trying
to
lose on points just stay in the game
and he had that he had to eat and i
definitely thought at the beginning he's
got too much for usic which he should
have had the man was a cruiserweight he
only went about 15 and a half down the
night either waited at 15 10 or
something fully dressed he'd been 15
stone he had the brawn he had the
strength of three men a bigger man all
around a good good array of boxing
skittles but did he use them i'll tell
you why i never used them he's hot and
desiring down on the goal together
ability and desire to wouldn't go
together if one's missing forget it
so because i know loads and loads of
bags of ability no art
and they're nowhere we're seeing against
fighters like klitschko and dillian
white aj pulled the trigger but then
after ruiz
he just doesn't look the same do you
think that is the reason or do you think
there's something else going on there
i think in my own mindset
the klitschko fight emptied his tank
that much and terrified him he's never
got over it because i even know i think
klitschko led him off the up for three
rounds yeah klitschko did nothing
he was out he got him down in the fifth
or sixth round he did nothing like three
rounds
they both took three rounds off didn't
they took three rounds off and i wonder
why
klitschko you could say that because
he's over three years old he's 42 or so
much aj
he was just trying to recover from a big
knockdown but i think once she got
knocked down proper like that and felt
the power and how it feels to get nearly
knocked out and the feeling's a horrible
thing it's the most horrible thing you
can ever go through i think he's a bit
too much for his mindset but he's never
got over it i don't want it to happen
again it's like having a bad car crash
in it if you have a bad crack i should
go and look forward to another one do
you
and that's how we do it with him uh how
do you say the rematch going between aj
and usyk
if he doesn't change his team around
and make adjustments music are beating
again
same same thing repeater but if he
changes his team up but how can you
breathe heart and desire and i ain't got
no how can you do that well i can't see
the corner screaming at him you expect
the corner
uh with with maybe three or four rounds
to go start to scream at him and give
him the fireman speech
but it wasn't it was just all that was
usually all i had was brilliant work
brilliant white round nine he's lost him
around get behind the jab
what
you don't need that in your corner when
you're trying to win titles but i do
think
his team rob mccracken
knew
that
usic could knock him out any time does
frightening getting ko yeah rob
mccracken and his team wanted to get him
to hear the final belt he wasn't
bothered about winning because they knew
you said could count him out and they
didn't want that to happen and they'd
settle for a point whilst they're trying
to keep him in the game
just trying to keep him in the fight
there's the apparently the
eddie hearns pushing uh dillian white as
the mandatory uh saying that he should
be next for tyson fury
um who who out of those the three
fighters do you expect tyson to fight
next
let's put it this way i don't think
white's getting past walling
it's a tough one i i i think otto wallin
he beats what he beats dillian white to
this area tough fight
and to me i might have to be honest with
if i was a gambling man
you've got to pick wallin because he's a
southpaw six foot five seventeen and a
half stone the kid can pop she's got
balls and he can hit
what i'm saying so white's got his own
problems
but his whites
in tyson's class no
there's nobody in this class tyson
however whoever he decides to fight next
will be a run out for tyson
and then he'll look at yousek
you sits on his mind he wants to unify
the belts whatever he wants to do after
that his own business but i know it'd be
hard for tyson to get motivated with men
like dillian white she's all with all
these
these five and six tier heavyweights
it's hard work for tyson though if you
want to see the best tyson fury put
tyson in hot water i like a fighting way
out of it that's the only way you see
tyson for you to perform
it's such a shame that we didn't get the
aj fight when when we should have done
it's a real [__]
well i was it was all definitely
definitely disappointing with that but
listen
the boxing fraternity ought to be
ashamed of yourself how to let that one
slip i don't know that's ridiculous
well the idea of pretty much closes make
make i mean in no other sport in the
world
do you have you know let's say football
two semi-finalists and then you get a
winner and a winner on the other side
and then they don't fight in the final
they go and rematch the other semifi the
whole boxing structure
is the only people who think boxing like
that makes sense or people have been in
boxing so long that they've forgotten
what real like normality is in my
opinion because every other school is
different
i quite agree
rematch pauses should be banned yeah you
know that's why they have contenders
isn't it yeah because all the men's
there working their way up to fight for
a title and with a rematch with all
these rematch clauses it could be three
years before tyson fights you said
joshua yeah it's and then then the past
the best then aren't they yeah
you know this is what i say this is why
i enjoyed dante wilder and tyson fury
because both men fought at the best
young men fought at the best not when
there was
five-year buster sell by date but but
even even then if if fury hadn't have
been in a vulnerable position coming
into the first fight would they even
have given him that you know so that's
how crooked boxing is and it is so
frustrating um one guy who's calling out
tyson at the moment which is very
strange in my opinion it's david haye um
good lord almighty uh
bizarre don't mention that idiot to me
that is a cracker jack that he's not a
crack pipe at mummy
that's been on the crack pipeline it
wants to kick up the ass
he wants to kick up the ass doesn't it
it's as fragile as a child
it's just
the only thing big about him you know
that is
what's up he's freaking eagle yeah
man's good for note and to talk about my
someone getting my listen i'll have a
reef made early for him if he wants to
get him with tyson i'll have a reef made
earlier his name on it rest in peace
david a
silly man
i mean considering he suffered
back-to-back defeats against tony bellew
um it is very strange when bellew
flattened him you know believes it
believe bill you've flattened him and he
was that billy's a big fat kid so he
goes on about people's conditioning
value has not got a body beautiful belt
bell you batted him from pillar to post
yeah i made him cry yeah the man's got
the man's got balls like man of fat peas
you can't see him
got no art no balls no notes and i'll
tell him to his face and this is a big
podcast isn't it david a keep my son's
name out of your mouth because you're
gonna end up in a grave mix with a big
red rose reef on it
you stupid man yeah matter of fact
people don't you don't don't talk about
furies no more because you ain't good
enough to talk about a fury because you
haven't got big enough to talk about one
you're a cowardly you're a cowardly
mother so stay in your own lane
and do some work and you're punching
things useless at that as well well the
strange thing is he had his chance to
fight uh tyson
obviously kind of man cuts his own eye
to get out of the fight
and uh
generally speaking
in regards to david his career obviously
he fought klitschko um lost that fort
bellew obviously lost doors he was a
cruiserweight champion
what did you think of david haye back
and back in the day
you know what do you think of his career
sorry i'm not knocking his achievements
he won two cruiserweight titles being
all he's always lacked art he could
punch and he had a good array of boxing
skills better than most not knocking
that at all but he's never been more i
remember him in the world in in the
world there in the worlds amateur boxing
yeah he was fighting some kind of some
other foreign kind of fella and he was
he's caught
get up and fight get up and fight you
can win this and he had no art then he
was gonna he was gonna down tools in the
amateurs you have to kick him up off the
stool
and i think he was fr you know
he'll come to my mind but i know all
about it he's never been at banks of art
david a but punching power yes ability
yes but he was lacking out and he was
managed well and he won the heavyweight
title for circus act who couldn't draw
straight punch value off a seven foot
two circus actor that's all i mean yeah
i i do think his obviously his
heavyweight career was exaggerated by
the farmer of course it was yeah i'm a
realist but i'm not knocking the man
he's got belts but i tell you what he's
a furiata so i'm a david a hater well
that that's the thing i must admit he he
does come across as a hater because
obviously
after the second fight he backed down on
everything he'd been saying about tyson
you know i was wrong i got proven wrong
and then
you know you had that big debate with
him and then coming into the third fight
he started saying things like oh i'm
completely ignoring the second fight
because the auntie wilder wasn't you
know was here or what he just came up
with a load of excuses for him and i
thought you know you were saying that
that was one of the best performances in
heavyweight history six months ago and
now all of a sudden you're completely
ignoring it and picking deontay again
you back down on a lot of what he said
to you
let me tell you does that not sum him up
though
he don't know his ass from his elbow
does he
doesn't know he's a good fighter who
does nothing about boxing nothing at all
yeah
it's a good job he'll add him boom in
his corner because he knows nothing
about boxing david he's like you know at
the end of the day how could somebody
get it that wrong but i'll tell you how
to get it that wrong the heart rules are
red and every every time tyson fights
he'll give his right nut to get tyson
beat because he don't like that he's
jealous of tyson always has been because
he knows when he looks at tyson
he shakes in his boots and he knows in
his own mind he looks in the mirror and
says fright and stiffer this guy i'm
still is
i know what you mean
with his wife he sees tyson fury
you know what i'm scared for this man
and it gets to him that's why every time
tyson fights he prays for him to get
winning and i'll tell you when he got
knocked down the fourth round i bet
david ainley shot his bolt in his
trousers but tyson got knocked down the
fourth round
i know what you mean like uh
david haye does come across as jealous
in regards to time
you know what a good phenomenal jealous
person never prospers in life he's had
his day he's had his day in the sun
let's move on from david a now because
at the end of the day demands what we're
talking about let's talk about it
by the way i'm up and down bt sport
every week and every month if you want
to try and pull me on it you can pull me
on it i'ma have a fight there and then
fisticuff me in him so so you actually
fight david hey go every other week
and i'm not hiding from noma yeah
i think i think
because i understand like he don't
respect the fury i don't respect him
enough said about him let's move on yeah
fair play
speaking speaking of the fury family
your other son is also boxing very big
name now tommy um obviously he had that
experience on reality tv
and his story's growing by the day
he's got a famous girlfriend you've got
jake paul talking about him
where do you see his boxing ability and
his potential
to to go in the sport of boxing
you know what
the kid
he's got plenty of boxing potential in
component she can box but he's
inexperienced you know it showed last
time out because when he last fought i
was more interested in how he handled
the affair more so than the fight i knew
he was going to win the fight yeah but
it's how we went about it you know
the pressure we need to work on the
pressure side more domain anything else
she's a 22 year old kid he had 10 junior
about she's only had seven pro fights
but he's never been on the big stage
he's been flung forward to fight so it's
as big as world title fights only seven
boats yeah so we've gotta work on his uh
on his energy first his mental state
walk into a fight and controlling his
emotions really but can he fight corsica
but if he doesn't fight he can't beat
jake paul or retirement to the eye um
it looks like it'll be a close fight in
my opinion no chance if it's a close
fight tommy's retired if tommy beats him
and struggles to beat him he's retired
from boxing
why do you say that
he's got
he's a youtuber
he's got to be knocking
jake paul out
he's got a he's got a boxer knock him
out as a youtuber and i'm not wasting my
time with people in the gym because i
haven't got a lot of time left at 56
year old so i'm not going to train with
somebody i've got no faith in so i've
told him unless you knock him out i'll
forget me with a boxing i'll walk away
because he's a youtuber yeah i mean i
respect that but obviously
the last guy who he struggled with
was
not even on the level of jake paul to be
in in reality
yeah i know me boxing him and jake paul
he'd be better move than jake paul i
mean he could avoid a punch better and
i'll tell you what he didn't want to do
what's his name again that philanthropy
taylor yeah you get a mom don't want to
get it and wants to survive and don't
get knocked out it's hard yeah he messed
tommy about he didn't come to fight jake
paul will come to fight i agree when he
does come he'll knock him out the other
one never come to fight he wants to
survive you want to make a circus act of
it i don't blame you because that's what
he had jake paul's no better than him i
think the other kid would avoid a shot
better than jake paulie could move
better than jake paul in it now well
yeah he was a wrestler so uh obviously
he's about
to do footwork
yeah he knew more about the fisticuffs
custom jake paul and jake paul's gonna
find out what it is because again
they're looking at what tommy's done
with anthony taylor that's why he's
fighting jake paul the beginning
you know that's why he took him because
he thinks i can't do him because they
think they've seen enough to give them
confidence but let me tell you something
fury's blocking coal tyson's had many of
them what was the performance and then
come back and done what he's done look
at the fight with otto welling comes
back and then does wilder yeah
when he fought otto walling would you
say he's gonna do that to wilder no
but it can bounce back but listen
talk cheap money buys houses there'll
never be another tyson fury tyson fury's
a unicorn he's done
it's his brother yes he's got all the
brothers
are they going to show that kind of
commitment and will to desire
god only knows but i feel in myself
tyson's out on his own but tommy and i
see tommy sputtering jake paul all over
the ring within four or five rounds
and if he doesn't it's over for him he
knows that no pressure tommy lad let me
tell you it will be called tommy fumbles
as well
well this is the this is the interesting
thing you mentioned about pressure
because obviously
tommy is growing up in a world full of
pressures full of you know difficult
things and and i think with tyson
there was a lot more time to ease into
the celebrity uh social media was
nowhere near as big as what it is now
and i think tommy is is kind of being
catapulted into this which can't be easy
for the lad um but but jake paul seems
to want to make it even worse and uh by
by jake putting these big bets on and
saying 500 grand and and you or you
change your name and all of this sort of
stuff you know if pressure's something
tommy is
maybe not comfortable with
jake paul is going to do everything he
can to ramp that up um
no because now we know
what we've got to do with tommy yeah
he's mine right you know it's not jake
paul it's not no he's beat better men
than jake paul already he's already beat
better than jake paul it's not jake
paul's thing it's occasions you know
it's a massive occasion with tommy you
know he's got his girlfriend he's got a
local look through he's got tyson he's
got the fury name but we're going to
work on that we could that can that can
be adjusted we can make adjustments jake
paul can't jake paul's a youtuber good
luck to the kid he's a businessman he's
doing a great job keep doing it and this
fight will be bigger than probably a lot
of world title fights but can tommy win
in
in tyson style yes he can
yes he can it will be a massive fight
and that and that's the thing is um you
know if you were to compare the fury uh
john uh sorry tyson and tommy's career
obviously they're not the same people
they're never going to be obviously
they're completely different people but
it's amazing how quickly tommy is
arriving on the scene in a huge money
fight i mean he's going to make millions
off of this and and it wouldn't just be
the fight it'll be after the fight
you'll be you know they're going to make
huge money together um beyond jake paul
where does he go from there in your
opinion well if he gets jake paul out
there would like to go for his brother
logan paul
also smashes what when he smashes jake
paul will take on his brother logan
smash him at all if he fancied it but
let me tell you when they see what tommy
does to jake paul they're not gonna want
they're not gonna want it looking back
at your uh i would like to talk about uh
your life as well and and you know not
all boxing talk but um
you know starting with with we've been
talking about tyson and tommy what were
they like as as kids young lads
well tyson was the softest child in the
world you know he got bullied at school
all he wanted was an hamburger
mcdonald's and to play with his toys
you know i used to play with a piece of
rusty iron on the makeshift hammer and
then house brick that was what he
proposed but that was material toys an
icebreaker
[Music]
there was a far cry from boxing i never
thought it was going to be boxes really
no because tommy used to play rugby
he used to be on the rugby team local
rugby team is a junior well he's built
for it isn't he tommy yeah he was he's
he's a very muscular lad
yeah he was a good group player tommy
was he played for salford reds juniors
and um he did that for about five years
but then he uh he wanted to be a fighter
when he got to about 14 or 15 he wanted
to be a fighter because he was looking
at tyson he was looking at his other
brothers without the other son young
king fury
my son knew he he he was he had eight
fights as heavyweights and he was
training all the time i think they got
all enthralled in all of it and it's in
them to do it what's in them what's in
you will come out of you
and the fight's in them
remind me um
i think you've got a son who has long
curly hair right
yeah
he
he makes me laugh so much i love this
guy he is one of my favorite interviews
to watch he talks so much sense i feel
like he should be on the tv uh doing
boxing punditries great
um
but you were you were a bare knuckle
boxer obviously at the start um which is
sort of where this was all born from i
guess the what we're witnessing now is
is kind of the journey really started
when you were you were doing that i
guess um
can you tell me what those days were
like when you were paying up a boxing
horrible because when you were doing
that it was just it was a case of
everybody was your enemy
there was a there was a opponent in
every street corner
when i was younger i couldn't walk down
the road without bumping into somebody
who didn't want to fight me you know was
fighting in the in the early 80s on the
football terraces or football illegals
coming out of the football fighting
every day before friday saturday night
every night every friday and saturday
night we had fights throughout my life
why did you keep going
because
would you not have just decided to stop
in
no
no loved it look forward to it if i
never had a punch-up on the night out
i'd had a bad night i never won them all
i got kicked to pizza after five but i
just loved it didn't care about getting
battered that's awesome so were you
involved in like organized fights where
people would bet on it and that sort of
stuff not really no it was just more
like people it was a pride thing and on
the thing yeah we stay up you know
something some people are saying
something about my people i'd say
something about theirs now just saying
let's just take this outside right
um i looked at your pro boxing record
obviously you moved into that and i was
impressed like obviously you had a
really good run at it um what was it
like making a transition into
professional boxing after you've just
been scrapping in uh you know the clubs
and whatnot well the thing is i i never
had one amateur fight never boxed
amateur at all really and i was 22
before i started and i was meant to be a
journeyman i was never i was never meant
to win anything because i was always in
the away corner i was always fighting
the prospects the ex-aba champions the
champions john furrier is in near the
corner but i still managed to win nine
out of this because i thought there tell
them one that i got robbed the only ones
i did lose i think uh was the last two
yeah i beat my buzzfeed area title after
and i was the first fight in two years i
used to box every 18 months yeah and
used to give me 200 quid so i couldn't
give up my day job you know but i i when
i thought mao he had 45 contests he
knocked out joe woo me the golden boy he
was a gold olympic gold medalist he
knocked him out in two rounds and i
fought him in my fifth fight ten ten
three minute rounds in ten fights
ten threes with five fights behind me
i've never been gone past six twos
before i'm fighting their ten threesome
if it's in my fifth fight i was never
meant to win anything but i did i
i could see that even even even the
fights are lost even like a wonder i
hadn't fought for two years yeah i got
like i got four days notice i was on the
front foot taking it to him the last
fight hadn't boxed for five here come at
the hospital the food poison the dodgy
chinese i was skintone needed a ground
so i got him with him after five here
front foot but my body just collapsed in
the fourth round through exhaustion
you know but if you get cold did you get
cold i've always been gay
but that what i took from the the
footage the limited footage obviously
that i've seen was
the desire to win
yeah you know you what you you had the
same desire tyson has actually yeah and
obviously he didn't have the amateur
learnings but you you had it i say
tyson a training camp i was doing that
after a day job i was working all day
and doing that
i'd get up in the morning put shifting
finish at five o'clock go back grab me
tea eggs and bacon and fried bread and
won't do that
i'm like what did i get three hundred
quid
i beat italian every week about four
days notice to fight the italian
heavyweight champion i'll beat him over
ten rounds
and and the mad thing is is that even
these days like some fighters i know who
are you know i'm talking like podium
level fighters yeah and yet they're
getting off at peanuts you know what i
mean it's it's it's a tough it's a tough
game
i have 13 i had 13 pro fights i never
made three run out of all of them
yeah i never made three grand out while
and it took me eight years to get them
13 fights yeah you know because when i
started winning a few these phones
stopped ringing they felt because the
only one employee losers and i said
don't do losing you book jump here i'm
gonna do the best i can i'm gonna try
and win but i just never did physicality
because they was athletes and i wasn't
because they was living in the gym there
was gym rats and i was coming off a
building site you fought bigger guys as
well i could see they were massive these
guys who you're in there with under all
of 45 fights i i was with i i thought
the best fighters of britain and europe
at some world-class building
and i didn't have a training camp i had
no dietitian
no strength and conditioning i would hit
the bag in the back of the house
i'm doing two mile run
yeah
my diet was all over the place i was
always as fat as a pig no time to run
because i put food to the table but
that's it i wasn't worth a carrot but
i've done me all but what you can see in
me
again
was heart and bollocks
forgot knocked out i got knocked he said
to me avoid the right tunnels i'm too
tired to point right up if he gets
moving
you're just scrapped and uh and i
couldn't definitely say that was the
attitude well that last fight you seen
there that was after five years late i
could see yeah i read up on your boxing
record and i was i was wondering what
happened in that time that made you not
box for so long
i'll tell you the truth i partied really
i went partying in spain all over the
world but i enjoyed the remains of it
but i skinned myself the misses left me
kids left me i was just a party boy
i thought buggery i'm getting 250 quid
i've got a day job i'm going to enjoy
some kind of life i used to go on bad
benders i was going to bender for a
month for two solid
you know what uh what's a a prime john
fury uh session like what what what kind
of party you know we're talking here
john how how deep was it
how deep was it
three or four brasses every night
two or three bottles of whiskey there's
any drugs going to have them at all
anything goes
you're a [__] legend john you're a
legend
i woke up one more looked in the mirror
three brass in the bed
and i thought you know what i was full
watching i thought you know what let's
get home to the kids i've had enough of
this [__]
that was hit that's what i used to do go
home the mr batten with a rolling pin
for about 10 minutes and i think you
know what get on with it i deserve it
back to work monday morning but then i
used to go walk about again that was
john fury you know but i always loved
and cherished my kids never really
wasn't really interested in wives i
don't like that on businesses because
they come and go don't they and you know
your kids stay away for the rest of your
life and i did well well i've been a
good father to them right even when i
was partying i've done what i did i made
sure they was all right and i said
listen something do what you'd be a man
take after your dad never let a woman
get you under the form live your life a
long time dead
get them guinnesses in
and i had a whale of a time kid yeah
so you uh you traveled a lot you said
spain what was what was spain like all
over the place yeah yeah i look up and
say right i'm going for the newspaper
and uh i'd come back three weeks later
you'd find me on the costas also
i set it for foreign newspaper on a
sunday morning and i've been dreaming 12
o'clock that night in porto bernous
party the night away with them lovely
dolly birds so um so we're not going to
see uh john fury getting told what to do
by his woman any time soon never in a
million years never
like my son said there's not a i'm not a
man boy is what can beat tyson fury
there's not a woman in the world can
tell john for you what to do and what i
do take them to bed
keeps them quiet
as long as you're saving them plenty
they'll keep quiet you're you're old
school john you're old school
yeah
do you think that's um he called me the
victorian father
do you feel like uh because you know a
lot of men uh in this generation we're
living in a very uh sensitive world
shall we say
uh yeah do do you ever struggle with the
fact that you know you really belong in
a different era maybe yeah that's why i
got no friends because look at these
other men they could ask the mrs can i
ever find a beer you know and i've never
done that in my life so i don't want him
as a mate do i he can't handle his wife
he's no point drinking my john fury is
he
you know because john feels like taking
his teeth out later on with three or
four guinnesses wallop check that yeah
i can't do a pedi i can't do a [__]
whips
on every woman
i'll tell you this much to give some
advice when a woman knows they can have
you they don't want you and they love
people like me deep down inside through
them they get wet knickers over it
stand on me it's the truth
no
i mean i look you've got a backbone at
the end of the day that's
that's a beast of a man that's why
tyson's a beast and a champion he is
that's the way i am
have women try to sort of uh get you
under the thumb a bit and try to put you
in your place a bit yeah
yeah but it's all always ended in tears
a lot of men out there are getting told
what to do by women these days it's it's
becoming quite normal well that's up to
them in it yeah you know if if my missus
try to tell me what for what to do from
day to day i just look at a straight and
say you know what this ain't working
yeah i've got to get away from you
because it's not going to work and i
don't want to be violent with you i
don't upset you in any way you're going
to have a bad lifestyle because i'm a
man and that you know something
leave a woman do what you want to do let
them go shopping let them come the food
let them talk to the mother slip talk to
the friends i'm not interested what the
woman does as long as my food's on the
table and there's a bit of but you know
what for me yeah that's all that matters
to me that doesn't want you quite a
straightforward man
yeah proper i tell them exactly where
it's at
don't spoil them
keep them well shot well
there's a fair [__] fall i'll never
leave you with that is there a is there
a kind of woman you look for generally
no
no no oh my god
my mother was the ultimate woman she'll
never be equal and the rest of them
don't come close that's why i'm like i'm
today
i know the feeling john i i'm i'm in
that regard i'm very i'm of a similar
opinion uh it is it's impossible to beat
your mother isn't it oh my mother's a
woman and a half there you go
and that's that's how she bred someone's
like she bred me and she got grandkids
like she's my mother was a proper woman
he looked after us worked and done
everything right and it was it was
repeat for 40 years
breakfast dinner tea work washed
cleaning up everything a woman does and
more she did it without complaint i
never asked for nothing as we call a
woman and now
beans on toast is our work from today in
it
[Laughter]
big big sunday dinner and a big slap up
meal beans on toast is a big core deal
why do you think things have changed so
much though because it's clear that the
world is changing and it has been
spoiled and i'll tell you what
the men
if you can call them that
has allowed it to happen that's why the
like they are today what they do john
fury don't do i love women i love
looking at them i love talking to them
they're a lovely glorious creature a man
can't do without one including myself
you know we put i put them on i put them
on pedestals you know you know there's
no great if god made anything better
than woman he kept it to himself i like
them all fatten sinners long and shorter
i'm going all day long i love them all
do they should they know the place in
john fury's like they should do but
listen i'm like my mother i'm like mama
yeah i love me or eat me i can't
you know but i mean no offense and no i
am to all those guys he's got to ask him
to go to the pub and be told what to do
can i go and see meatballs i feel sorry
for your chaps but there's nothing you
can do because you've allowed it to
happen
how do you just just we'll move on from
this in a second but i do appreciate the
the raw honesty
you know if you are in a situation like
that because i'm sure there'll be men
out there watching this let's be honest
who are in that situation how do they
take um back their sort of manliness
good question what a good point matt
i can answer it with an even better
answer grow some nuts
throw some nuts and be a bit sterner
with them and say listen you
dully
this is how i want it so i want to live
my life and if you can't provide me with
the needs i need i'll move on
if you can't have that move on
i'm trying to live with somebody you can
find that with
but they're all gone then women by the
way yeah in a new era they're hard to
find like hen's teeth a woman like i'm
after
you don't exist anymore
oh yeah hello brother i hear that
uh
woman's a good woman now is rocking
horse crap you can't find it
never will
yeah one in a million john oh god um
i was thinking about your your sort of
day-to-day life there when you were
talking about what you like to do i was
wondering what what an average um day or
week or whatever is like for you what
what kind of things you get up there
with hobbies and what's your diet like
what what's your general life like i do
a lot of exercise now i'm older i run
every day you know i do a bit of back
work in my own property you know where
i don't want to die too much i love food
you know i do a lot of off-grid living
now you know i'm i'm in i'm off grid
today because i've come out of my
caravan now miles from anywhere in the
field to talk to you because that's the
way i like i like solace and i know the
world has escaped me and it's not how i
want it to be so i choose to live like
this now you know but i i eat all my own
food cook it on an open fire i'll eat
anything
snails frogs whatever i can get the odd
pigeon at two it'll be in my pan if it's
there really you know yeah do you do a
bit of hunting and stuff yeah yeah i do
yeah i'm a good shot with a catapult
yeah
really not a good shot with a catapult
yes another dna thing and i can get what
i need off the land you know i ate raw
berries off the edge and all that kind
of thing there's plenty of there's
plenty nutrition amount on edges grown
this time of year now you know the red
berries what you get they're good for
your heart cholesterol blood pressure
everything all them things are out there
natural remedies we're just going to
find them you know i do i drink a lot of
stinging nettle tea as well
you know if you like taste you're in
trouble but john fury don't do taste to
do nutrition
if it tastes as good as banfield
i mean unfortunately yeah that's that's
that's often the truth do you uh you
know obviously used to be a party lad uh
what about uh drinking and that these
days do you drink much
no
no i'll give it all up yeah i'll give it
all because i see myself going down the
wrong road and i've got that prison when
i come out of prison i give it all up
you know what i'm saying right because
the drink led me to prison the way i
lived my life then led me to the jail
center so i'll give it up as a bad job
john fury knows when to leave things
alone and if you don't leave it alone
when you've gone through i've gone
through something wrong with you in the
head you know i just wanted a quiet life
now
so it's obviously that that wildlife led
you to prison can you tell me a bit
about sort of how that came about and
what was it like being locked up
yeah listen i'm one of them again when
in rome do as romans do when i got
locked up i knew i couldn't get out so i
thought i forgot about the outside world
i thought right
bring it on
they'll never break me because they put
me in there to break me they won't break
john fury i said you give me 25 years
won't break john furrier never you know
i got on with it i did my gym enrolled
on courses i made use of my time i
wasn't just going to waste it something
i've been feeling sorry for myself but
i'm in here now
i'm going to get in shape educate myself
and put my best foot forward and have
the undying desire to get out better
when i went in and i did
come out sensible
wiser and everything due to listening to
experienced professional people
you know
non-travelers
you know i learned a lot to learn how to
integrate with people how to talk to
people respect people i've always been
respectful my father always said treat
people as you like to betray yourself
give respect you'll get it back that's
how i built my life that's what i did in
jail i give prisoners respect to
respected me
inmates
staff
governors
they're all all great with john fury
do you have any fights in prison
no he didn't come near me because what
happened but i thought they looked at me
as some kind of uh
killer or someone you know he kept
saying he might pull my eye okay
that's what they think i want to keep me
two eyes and all that business you know
all right so
so the story got round of how you ended
up in prison after yeah for those who
don't know um i you you took a guy's eye
out in a fight yeah yeah
and um so
you know you mentioned your dad um yeah
what was he like out of interest
quiet
he never around his life you know you
know my father aided confrontation
he was terrified of confrontation and i
watched it all my life
and i thought to myself you know what
people used to put me dad down used to
like bullying a little bit and i thought
as soon as i can get a better man's
strength and be a bit of able going i'm
going to stand up for myself and i'm
going to put our family on the
we're going to be no more taking [__]
off people because when i get strong
enough i'm going to make a point with
all these luck and that's what i did
and it made from being a kid to make a
point all my father suffered i was going
to unsuffer him
enough in the years to come and i did
so so when you did you did get that
strength that was part of the the thing
that had sort of triggered you of being
disrespected being talked down to as
your dad was you weren't never thought
down to nobody ever he never disaffected
anybody he respect everybody is nice to
everybody but you know it's nice to be
nice but you can be too nice that's life
always remember that
it's nice to be civil you've got to know
when to turn the switch and turn to
somebody else
so so in that case you know obviously
the fight that that obviously led you to
prison what let what led to that fight
happening
drink
drink again
you know that's what it does because
when drinks in whits out you know when
when people's drunk you see the real
person don't you yeah when people's
drunk the real person appears
and that person appeared and i didn't
like it
i thought you know what
this is only going to end one way bad
and it did
yeah run me time
you know he's just high i've lost i've
lost it i've lost a lot as well i can't
travel i'm never going to see me sunbox
again i've had a nightmare for a decade
i was i've done five years in prison out
the door five year on probation couldn't
breathe a move i still can't if i if i
shout to if i fart too loud i'm back in
jail
that's the way it is you're just waiting
there like vultures to take john fury's
life
so i've got to take a bit [__] myself
that's why i'm on mail
your void people i like the flag
you're someone who's learned a lot
obviously from from the wrong things
that you've done yes um when you watch
tyson
going down a very similar road because
you'd been there it must have tore you
up a lot inside what was what was it
like having to watch someone sort of
self-destruct when they'd been so high
it was absolutely a nightmare probably
the worst thing i've ever been through
i've been through a lot myself i've been
to the jail i've been through death
i've done the dying the suffering and
the pain i've done all that airline in
my life it's been a story of my life but
to see tyson like he was that nearly
broke john fury because if anything
happened to that boy i killed myself
if he would have anything would have
happened to him i'd have done myself in
couldn't live without him
or any other member of my family if
anything happened to my kids mate any
one of them i'd be stringing from a tree
ten minutes later because i wouldn't
want to live without them that's such a
powerful
thing to say to me like you know
a lot of people look at you as a tough
guy but obviously you love them so much
that it would be just too much for you
to handle oh yeah for sure
and i nearly died my dad died
really nope but there you go was that
what sort of percent you spiraling
originally
it did but except that he's an old man
and he was very ill you know he did have
66 years in life you know but these are
my children you know and i think no
father should die but no no child should
die before his father you know and i
don't think i could unbelieve i'm honest
about it you know what what would it be
for me life without my kids because i
haven't got nothing else in my life i'm
not interested in money i'm not
interested in the fame or blitz or
plastic friends or nothing i'm
interested in my sons and their
well-being and what they can do you know
and people say to me
you live like you haven't got five
pounds i said i'm rich in other things
my son is the best heavyweight fighter
on the planet he's the best ever come
out the uk you know all my sons are
doing well they all love each other
they've all got one another's backs so
that's makes me a trillionaire if i can
sit back in my shepherd's foot
in my off-grid living in it and observe
all my sons doing that i'm a
trillionaire money can't buy them money
comes and goes i've had money i've never
had any money there's not much
difference in it my book still i'm still
fed the wild birds still get fed don't
they
they've got no jobs they've got no
careers they've got nothing but they
still eat
and i've always it
i've always had food that's good enough
for me and i've always had so much sleep
it feels like
it feels like um
you'd probably be happier being the dad
of a champion than being champion
yourself
yeah
i would number one probably was never
good enough to be a champion
you know
it says like this
you're either ten times better than your
father i'm not as good you know brendon
ingle said to me years ago you john are
the most underachieved fighter i've ever
seen in milo
he said i could have met you a champion
he said but there's no sponsors can't
sell gypsies nobody wants us back a
gypsy there's no sponsors can't sell you
people buy tickets to watch the gypsy
get beat up
and that's where you lie in boxing well
i said okay thank you about 13 fights
good day
saluted them and walked off into the
sunset and i just i just thought about
it then as total abuse i've been abused
in the boxing world for 13 years but did
i learn somewhat from it yes i did as it
brought us where we are today yes it has
does it give me a world for boxing
and knowledge of boxing yes it does so
yeah all went down well
you know when you were um i think you
moved in with tyson when he was on his
road to coming back what was it like
living with someone going through all of
that every day and trying to pick them
up
a horror story
because i i was trying to let him out
besides if he went to the shop on his
own or he went to the toilet i was
thinking he was going to kill himself
so it drove me mad
i nearly cracked up myself i thought no
don't do that
you can't lose your head here you've got
a bit of rock here
you've got to be the father you've
always thought you was and get him
through this
you know but i'll tell you i couldn't
have done it on my own without the rest
of you he would be sons and all that you
know his mother they all chipped in to
help him out maybe we already wouldn't
have been here you know
you know what i just thought he's got to
be up 24 hour watch and that's what
we're on for two years
it feels like um
now you're getting all the rewards for
putting that work in me
it looks like that now i thank god every
day for it you know i just thank god
because all i wanted to be back then was
a father to his children you know and a
husband and just normal and be alive
we've come from we've we've made the
transition now to somewhere else
and to me this is it we've landed
somewhere on cloud9 but do we deserve it
do we deserve it does tyson deserve what
we've been through yes we do well i
think i think where you've landed is is
um is the word greatness
for tyson fury yes yeah he's he's he's
now to me cemented his legacy
as
the the the best fighter of the
generation you know um
it's unbelievable what he's done and i
feel like with his heart his will his
determination and his skill set that
basically
i don't think there's anyone who can
overcome him now
because he's so well-rounded it reminds
me back when you'd watch mayweather and
you think no one can beat this guy
because he's got every style he's got
everything he needs but i don't know
what more tyson can do he's won every
professional title is to win you know
he's unbeaten you know
where does he go but then again there's
challenges and new challenges coming
through every day these young
heavyweights are cropping up everywhere
aren't they i'm no longer there is some
good talent out there but are they any
good to tyson at the moment though
because titan's on a roll he's in the
prime of his life he's slowly just
turned 33. in the world's oyster and
he's rolling he's on fire the the
amazing thing as well is obviously there
was a period where the media went after
him
and and now to look at where he is as as
a mental health advocate
and and someone who
you know what is what's been your
experience with mental health because i
feel like you're an old-fashioned guy
probably didn't think too much about
that back in the day how did how did
that journey go for you
i was born with a mental health problem
i've had it all my life
but my father's one of them he said look
if you know you've got a problem there's
no cure for it don't worry about it
that's what my dad used to say if you
know you have a problem but there's no
gear over it don't worry about it do
your day-to-day chores and if you don't
you'll never have a family you'll never
have a woman you'll never have nothing
to your own because everybody will think
you're adept
and incapable looking after a family so
the mental health thing got pushed in
the cupboard but did we have it of
course we had it
so your dad knew that you were different
so to speak yeah he was different my
father was medicated all his life mental
health
really he's on strong medication my
father it's the registry hmm
yeah i i'm already interested because my
mother
all like it yeah the two brothers my two
brothers what died they would day with
mental health sufferers yeah you know
all of us are the same
you know just but i am a little better
because i'm used to being like it it
must be something special then to see
tyson become
basically one of the biggest if not the
biggest actually
mental health
advocate in the world
it thrills me it's a thrill because you
know
since i've took my time in life i've
slowed down a lot i've noticed the
suffering in the world it's mental
health especially in young people 40 and
under you know and if we can help in any
way shape or form even me we're helping
because i think it needs to be brought
to the front of the queue addressed
properly never mind coronavirus this is
a pandemic on its own mental issues for
people and if i can help anybody i will
and tyson well you know it brings tears
to his eyes when people say you've saved
me life i can see him fill up and i fill
up i get tears in my eyes and it's hard
to swallow when people say to me you've
saved me life i've been doing it before
this uk tour yeah and the amount of
mental health suffers i've helped and
seen and spoke to is unreal but
sometimes i keep getting choked up so
i'm a very emotional person and when
somebody says john you've saved me life
i feel like going in the toilet crying
for half an hour yeah he is a joy yeah
well especially in men because and
that's not to say women don't matter men
apparently are three or four times more
likely to commit suicide than women
especially at a younger age
and uh
you know saying
a six foot nine
20 stone man who's heavyweight champion
of the world open up about his issues it
can only be a tremendous thing for for
men everywhere to say if the heavyweight
champions say it's not all right and
he's not all right then anyone can
absolutely and you know the what the
world looks at tyson known and all the
light yeah you don't just look at him as
tyson the world heavyweight champion
yeah he looked at him for strength to
look at him as a pillar for mental
sufferers somebody to look at click on
the internet watch his videos and this
that and the other and they're having a
better day yeah from that moment on
when he gets back up twice in that
fourth round that's it it only adds to
to the legend that's almost a better
fight for the story of tyson than if he
just went and blasted him in a round you
know it just it adds to the legend for
sure
uh let me tell you
that's why tyson gets up
that's why he gets up for all those
people who's looking at him and
depending on him because i'll tell you
what he's going through his everybody's
on the canvas
people are watching me people need me to
get up and show different things to
happen if i want to save lives from here
on i've got to get up but i've got to
win
that's tyson's mindset
keeps it going
well i've only got one final question
john or
how would you like to be remembered
i'd like to be remembered as a straight
talking fella
and a good father
that'll do me i think i think you've i
think you've got that mate um it's been
an absolute pleasure thoroughly enjoyed
it and uh thank you
we we do a live show uh whenever the
fights are on and at some point i'd love
to get you on the live show to get your
opinion on what's happening in the fight
it'd be fantastic let me just say one
thing i apologize to everybody out there
but i might have offended the way i am i
can't look the way up put my arts in the
right place i help anybody i'll give to
anybody if people knock on john fury's
don't they need help jump for your help
but i apologize for my behavior and how
i am that's just me
you know if you like to hear john fury
like him if you don't i'll switch off
the channel
but thanks for having me on the show
anyway big big thanks john you take care
and i'll see you soon mate cheers
god bless
and that was john fury on the pain game
podcast there's just nobody quite like
him is the don't forget if you haven't
already hit that subscribe button on the
true jordan youtube channel and the
notification bell on or whatever the
[__] you've got to do these days and hit
that like button thanks to everyone
supporting this podcast it's on apple
and spotify if you want to listen to it
and i'll see us on the next one